Hey guys, where am I?
Where the fuck am I?
Oh, there I am.
Hey guys, I'm late to war apparently.
Apparently, there's a war...
The reason why I chose 1pm is that there is a great war going on.
The Great Russ War that I may or may not have started.
And I'm late.
It's like...
And the thing is, Gumi is not online to let me out of the house.
I knew it.
I was like, tell me the code, Gumi.
And she's like, no, I'll let you out.
I'll be online.
And she's not online.
I fucking... I did.
I knew it.
I knew she wasn't going to be online.
I was like, oh, there's no way.
I don't think she's going to be online.
There's no way.
And then like...
Oh my god.
Anyway, I'm trapped in the house.
And I have to slash kill so I can get out and be at the...
I have to fucking...
I have to...
No, nobody's on...
I don't live there.
I was like, oh man.
Just tell me the code, Gumi.
No.
I'll be there to let you out.
Fucking knew it.
I fucking knew she wouldn't be there to let me out.
I had a feeling.
I was like, I don't think she will be.
I was like, tomorrow's the last day of rest, Gumi.
Oh, wow.
Hello, hello.
Does anybody live down here?
Hello, I'm stuck.
Please, let me out.
Please, I want to join the war.
Please.
Oh my god, please.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I'm stuck here.
Well, time to slash kill.
There's nothing else to do.
Time to slash kill, guys.
Oh my god, goodbye.
I loot.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking...
Okay, there's a great war right here.
There's a ginormous wall right here.
War right here.
Hello.
Oh yeah, I'm late for the war.
I literally...
By the way, so like, that's why...
Oh shit.
Well, hello everybody.
I'm here for the war.
Wait, what?
You said you better wake up tomorrow.
And I actually woke up tomorrow.
Now you told me I should not have woke up.
Hey, I'm alive.
Yeah, sure.
Let me fucking gear up first.
Isn't there a war going on right now?
Oh, okay.
One man?
I thought this is two men.
Wait, who said...
Who told me to do this mission?
Who even told me to do this?
Who said that?
Yeah.
Alright, I am ready.
Oh, wait, are we?
Wait a minute.
Wait, wait, are we?
Yeah?
Wait.
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
I think...
Wait, are you doing what I think you're doing?
Wait, are you...
Are you doing what I think you want to do?
Beast?
Are you?
Oh, my God!
Anyway, it's time to wait 188 seconds.
Okay.
Well, tomorrow I go.
I hate tomorrow I go.
Are we winning?
Are we...
Are we at least winning?
Alright, we got to wait 140 seconds, I guess.
I guess.
I hit another throne.
Alright, long story short.
I was told that there was gonna be another war today.
And I had to get on at like 1 p.m.
But I didn't realize they were starting the war at exactly...
You know, I could've just gone here and ran over.
You know what?
Fuck it.
I'll just go over here and run over back home.
What is this base?
Whose house am I in?
How...
Where am I?
Oh, fuck.
I don't...
You know what I said yesterday was a bad day?
Today's the bad day.
I lied.
It was actually today.
Is that for the paratroopers?
Where the fuck are the parachutes?
How is there no parachutes?
Oh, and now everybody spawned there.
Like, how is there no parachutes on like a paratrooper land?
Like, I don't understand.
Like, I actually...
Alright.
Alright, anyway.
Anyway, I guess we got 40 seconds left.
So yeah, I was given a message that...
Remember to come online at 1pm for the Great War.
Great Rest War.
That we may or may not have started.
I swear, I felt like I saw people tweeting a picture of it.
But I did feel like the assassin of the Archduke.
It did feel like that.
The one person that started all of this.
I just took the shot.
And now there's the Great War that I unfortunately have to be part of now.
I think there's like 3 hours left of the rest of it.
So that's why I was like, you know what, fuck it, we might as well.
Like, cloth, armor.
Is there anything for me?
Where's our Lurkling outfits?
Oh no, did we run out of Lurkling outfits?
Okay, maybe...
Wait, no.
Cancel.
Alright, I wanna...
Do we have any more Lurkling outfits?
We don't.
Oh my god, what do we do?
Wait, what do we do now?
I took the only source of food.
Oh my god.
What do we do?
We don't have...
Well, do I go in there naked?
I don't know if I should take those...
That, I'll just wear this.
Like, they won't shoot me, right?
If I wear...
If I wear a non-Lurkling outfit.
I just wanna wear clothes.
They won't shoot me if I wear something that's like...
Unrelated to the Lurkling outfits.
Like, we don't have...
We ran out.
Are you...
Are you okay?
Are you okay over there?
Oh, she was not okay.
I'm sorry.
Not okay, but thanks for the meds though.
Thanks for the guns.
I really appreciate it.
That's unfortunate.
That she was not okay.
Whoa!
Bro, I don't know if I wanna go up there.
I'm a little scared.
I don't know if I wanna...
Oh my god, there's like the taxi.
There's...
Oh my god.
I'm scared.
It's
like...
I looked for only a second.
I...
Oh my god.
Are you... Fuck, I'm tired.
I looked away.
Was it dead?
I fucking knew it was...
Oh my... What the fuck is all of this?
Like, how do I get out?
Oh, that's how.
Okay.
There has to be parachutes, right?
Alright.
Oh my god, time to fucking loot...
Loot random shit here.
I just...
I just wanna live.
Oh my god.
I miss my old stuff.
Guys.
I think war is not cool.
I don't know.
War might not be cool.
No way.
Guys, I just...
Just have a feeling that war might not be as cool as I thought it'd be.
I don't know.
Just a feeling.
Just a...
Just a little suspicion.
Oh.
Hey.
Wait, taxi guy?
Is that you?
Oh my god!
Taxi guy!
He shot...
He's shooting taxi guy!
He's shooting him!
No!
Taxi man!
Nobody is safe!
Not even...
Taxi man!
No one is safe!
No!
Not...
Taxi man!
Where the fuck is my fucking...
Did they take my loot?
They took my loot, didn't they?
They took it.
My body is gone.
My body is actually...
It's gone.
It's gone!
It's fucking gone!
Oh my god.
Is there anything?
I might as well not even grab loot.
I feel like I grab loot and I die.
I feel like...
I feel like I grab loot and then it's over.
It's alright.
Is he a bad guy?
Oh my god!
Wait, how do I reload this?
There we go.
Alright.
I could have shot him but I fucked up.
I didn't reload.
I...
Guys...
I don't know if I want to...
be up here.
Boomy, where were you?
I forgot to slash kill!
I knew I should have trusted you with my loot!
I fucking knew it!
If he was part of my team...
Well, too bad.
I knew it.
I can't!
I'm part of a...
I can't just respawn!
I'm literally fighting for my...
Fuck, okay.
This is not fair.
Why are we...
They have guns.
This is not fair.
They have...
I...
I wish...
I wish we had guns.
I...
I will open this door...
and let them in.
I would...
I'm dead.
What?
Oh, thank you.
No, I don't.
They never gave it to me!
I never got it!
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, hold on.
Doki, does it say Peacekeeper on the top, right?
No, it doesn't.
Yeah, then you're good.
You can take guns.
Oh my god, thank fucking god!
Oh my god, I'm so happy.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I can finally use guns.
Oh my god, thank god.
I can finally...
Can I get an AK?
There is hope.
I'm here.
Here's one set.
You can use this.
It's the Great Ted War.
Yeah, I know!
I got killed by Ted several times!
I know!
Dude, it's the Great Ted War.
It's happening.
Okay, nevermind.
Yeah, yeah, nice.
Oh my god.
The ammo are up here.
Where's ammo?
Okay, nice.
Guys, which one's the AK ammo?
Is it the rifle?
It has to be the rifle, right?
Yeah.
Alright.
Wait, how do I change the skin of the gun?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey!
Oh my god, I finally have a gun.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
You wanna see my gun?
I got dropped just for it.
Look at this.
It's me.
Yeah, you got my gun too!
Let's go!
Oh my god!
That's me!
So why are we at war again?
Why?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh my god, I got to see it.
Guys, if you watch one hour of my stream, you get this gun.
Guys, you just need to watch one hour.
What are you guys doing?
We have to get back into battle!
Our enemies!
There's so many!
But, Shaggy, this is my gun.
Okay, okay, okay, Shaggy.
But look, look.
This is my gun.
It has my face on it.
Is that cool?
Isn't that cool?
This is my face.
It's not moving.
You have two faces?
Yeah, look, look.
This is my face.
Are you a Siamese twin?
Yeah, isn't that cool?
They created this just for me.
That's so unique.
I don't know!
Anyway, I guess we go off back to war.
Alright.
Back to war.
Sorry for this ad break, guys.
I'm taking the iron dragon!
Anyway, ad over.
I'm coming with you!
Are we?
Guys,
I don't know if I want to push up.
It's a little scary over there.
Shaggy!
It's way too laggy over there.
Who's a good guy?
Oh my
god!
Shaggy!
Go get him, Shaggy!
Do you think Shaggy got him?
I don't know if he was bad person.
I just shot him for the sake of it.
I could have not been a bad guy, but like who knows what fucking that was anymore
It's okay, it's okay.
I'm okay.
I'm not okay, but I'm okay
Are you guys okay over there?
Oh, they were not okay
Guys they're dead.
Oh my god, it's so laggy over on the other side
Okay guys, yeah, yeah, it's pretty bad.
It's pretty bad over there
Okay, goodbye
So much this is the one guy that hate the most
Literally, literally if I could I would erase him from existence I would go if I could travel back in time and they're like, oh, yeah, I'm trying If I could travel back in time and erase one person from existence it would be dead It would be dead Fuck that guy Fuck that guy
I Swear to God one day.
I will go back in time and make sure your mama does not meet your papa.
Well, I will I will fuck your mama
I will make sure you die die
Make sure he doesn't come back.
Who even was the guy that I finished?
Was it Ted?
As long as it's Ted, I'm happy
I don't know we should go in there.
That's the... I don't even know
Yeah, like it's yeah like I don't even know what how laggy it is over on that side over the actual battlefield
Whoa JK, I didn't beat that You have heals You have heals, I'm mad Do you have heals?
Do you have heals?
Please I killed somebody but I don't know who My god, thank you Yeah, yeah, I killed somebody I don't even fucking know who That's called knowing the drop off of your gun that you I just got I just got this Bro, I'm shooting everybody anyone I see that's not green If you're not green you die I don't even care if they're allies.
I don't even care if they're allies Don't even I don't even know who's an ally anymore Take out the to the West, where are they?
How do we get the how the fuck do we get there
We're supposed to go to the West but I feel like the moment I head to the West I die I think the travel to the West is way too dangerous
Well people keep trying to grab these rocks and we just have Yeah, yeah, that's what I was doing too I see like now Only bow and LM over on the other West let them handle that I'm fucking just shooting here.
I got my gun.
Oh God parachuted and fucking died
I'm looking I'm looking Oh car.
Oh shit.
Oh Shit I saw like people walking.
Oh Whoa, I see the sniper.
Yeah.
Yeah Bro, how is he able to make shots?
It's so laggy.
How can you shoot like this thing?
I'm going back.
I'm going back
I Don't know great run.
I swear to God that I swear Swear to God if I make this travel and I get shot in the foot.
I swear.
Oh, I swear to God.
Oh My god need heels
Do we even have
I Mean I'm here's left.
Oh my god.
Are we broke?
Are we just kind of been running around?
But has never actually joined the church, are you What the fuck
I really I like when people look at me Where the fuck are the heels?
Hey, I'm trying to find the heels Yeah, yeah You wait you got heels.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Yeah.
No, I saw you parachute all the way there and got shot off the sky
All right, I Mean they're over there trying to shoot from the other side.
Do I guys do I go over there chat?
Do I?
Do I attempt to go over there or like or do I say do it go in?
Go and die.
Thanks guys.
That's so motivating that
I Don't know you fucking took me to the plane and it crashed I literally just logged in you took me to the plane and then I died I don't know that seems that seems like a good reason, you know You see my name
Yeah, you know how did you know, you know how you could get it I know how you could get it Well, this is my Yeah, yeah, this is my exclusive rest gun skin and you can get it to by watching one hour of My stream at Doki bird at twitch and then you can get a gun as cool as this I Heard that if you give this up in your channel to you get the kaisen a hoodie if you okay,
but nobody cares about that
Yeah, but like but this gun is even better than a hoodie guys look at it That gun is so cool.
Yeah.
I wish I was holding it so I could press n to inspect it Oh, yeah, I would show it off to my guess.
You gotta watch one hour of the stream then
Okay, yeah
Anyway, sorry add over
Okay, what did he just die in front of me
That man just died
Whoa, I Don't know I don't know if they're good or bad people.
I'm just taking the shot.
I take the shot
I'm scared.
I don't know.
I Can't see oh my god, I don't know.
They're bad.
I just take the shot
Oh my god, that lag is terrible they're not gonna
I Maybe we shouldn't go in there
All right time to get my gun and then get that gun again It's up here No, it was like here.
There you go guns All right, guys look it look I got my gun again
Ammo whoops cancer Guys We're sucks guys We're fucking sucks I should have stayed in the tire tower
See clothes helmet this all right I need pants What the fuck is going down down there?
It's your pants.
Okay, there is There we go, wait, I have to wear this Then I can't wear this oh That's dumb Coming grandma Okay, what's going on with somebody and grandma's like what's going on here?
Oh Wait, you're not the grandma fucker, okay Wait, where's the grandma
Where are you?
Where's the grandma fucker?
Your name is hello Neptune Yes That's fine, well, I'm Shaggy, are you anyone?
I didn't see anything.
I can't even put you in the back, huh?
Are you fucking grandma's going to war?
No, I'm here Yeah
Yeah, and you're gonna spend
Yeah, I was just looking for some help I I don't really have a faction I'm just kind of here I'm looking to have a good time.
I'm really like to give you a bag and it's no You're gonna share a sleeping bag together, all right, you know you do you Shaggy you do you go go to leave You really believe your stress Relieve your stress Shaggy.
You seem to have a lot of it I'm never not relieved Gonna give you guys privacy
What are you talking about?
I'm trying to be a civil gentleman
I'm getting to the throne right now
I Back at it we go War changes people it sure does
He's too far gone guys, he's he's too far gone guys he's
Now now he's with grandma Yeah, now he's with the grannies
Doesn't matter if you're friendly it doesn't matter to me It doesn't matter you think I care I've been through all fuck okay never
Okay, maybe it does matter to me
I Need to find this guy, where is he?
Like, where is he shooting me from?
Even shooting me from oh my god, where's my body?
Wait, it's my gun
Just died
My god
How did I get robbed that fucking fast
Checking the grass outside the window.
Okay.
All right.
I'll try Guys, I don't even care who wins this fucking bat war anymore.
I just want my gun I just I'll find her no It's not no, I don't see a gun here.
I see 5,000 bodies you think they'll notice me?
No
Pick this up though
Yeah Nothing here.
Nope.
I don't see anything
My god, I'm fucking back to I guess I'll go grab my stuff again
You got stuff for me Come over here.
I Wouldn't take all of these but but take some Alright, don't worry.
Leave some here.
Don't worry.
I'm leaving some after I take all of it Some of these I don't worry I'll start I'm just telling you of my full inventory Twinkles.
Oh Shit, okay
He's already left All right
All right, okay, there you go Guys I'm just gonna grab my gun again.
I'm It Never ends.
This is like actually my purgatory now.
Now I know what my purgatory is.
This is it This is my purgatory
This is my purgatory right here Okay
The never-ending I'm not going back I'm not going back.
They can have this war.
I'm fucking done.
I I'm never going back.
It never ends
What the what the what the fuck oh Come on Wait, it's not even my skin.
Wait, you're right Well, you're right, okay, give me a sec.
I need a swap skins.
I forgot the swap skins guys Yeah
You know what You know what I think I think I'm tired of war Ellen I think I'm really tired of war
I For more mines for now, I'm a criminal
They won't know how would they know she has a one hour I'm running I'm deserting He won't know it was me.
I'm fucking out of here
I Thought of you I'm fucking up I'm done.
I'm done with war.
I'll fuck that's over There's no turning back now
They can have it I'm fucking I'm a free I'm a free bird now I'm a free bird
I'm done
I'm done with it all they can have all of this.
You know what?
I just want to do I I just I just want war to be over.
I'm tired
Why would you be here?
Oh
Back to looting the items This cycle, I have gifted them 200 AKs, but that's okay That's okay.
I didn't need it anyw- and 200 meds I'm just gonna stop taking meds Don't stop guys The idea is that you just gotta stop taking your meds guys like at this point OH MY GOD I CAN'T EVEN OPEN BOXES
Just stop taking meds guys at this point.
There's no point.
OH MY GOD I CAN'T EVEN TAKE MY OWN GUN It's over It's so over
No, it's lag It's the lag It's actually so laggy right now
It's so laggy I just- I just want my GUN Oh my god, I think the issue was that I was wearing the I was wearing the The lurkling outfit.
That was a problem Hey It's so laggy.
I can't even open boxes anymore
Please Please Okay, please.
I just oh my god, please Whoa, you used a gun yet?
No, like it's so laggy.
I can't open boxes anymore
Like can you open boxes twinkles?
Oh My god, where did the gun go?
Where did it go?
Can you open boxes?
Wait, I think I got a DC I got
That was way too that I I just I couldn't do anything I
Just like yeah, I'm gonna I'm gonna relog I feel like nobody heard me I Okay, we're gonna reconnect.
I Mean could see me.
He saw me so I didn't DC.
I Know I didn't DC cuz he literally saw me.
Oh My god, how long is this war it feels like nobody is progressing How I feel I?
Feel like nobody is making any progress I'm just throwing our bodies into everything until it's over
Like is anywhere safe, oh
My god, thank God I got it Okay, I'm just gonna grab these I'm not even gonna grab clothes Giving up I don't need clothes anymore All right
Yeah sitting on the throne is the objective I'm just like that's not even what I want to do Has nobody ever asked what I want to do?
No Everybody just assumes I want to be part of this war Nobody ever asked how I'm doing Everybody just gives me a gun and assumes that this is what my life is That's it.
That's what everybody keeps putting pressure on me.
I just sometimes I just I just I just want to live my life I'm tired of killing.
I'm so tired
Oh My god, I just saw the rocket I just I just saw a rocket guys
I Just All right, all right, let me see Gumi Where are you?
I'm tired of war.
I want peace
I Just I Just I Is there a sanctuary Sanctuary Sanctuary for refugees from war.
Is there a sanctuary doing art?
I like how they're like, we're out here doing art.
That's our sanctuary, alright.
Alright, let's see if I survive.
Oh my god.
Wait, it's done in 5 minutes?
Wait, they're like in there.
Wait, they're in there.
How did they get in there?
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute, they're in, in.
Wait, dude, wait, it's possible.
Wait,
Sakuna, are you in there?
Sakuna, is that you?
Wait, we finally met up.
Yeah, we're finally here.
We finally bumped into each other.
All the supplies are gone.
War is a terrible thing.
Yeah, wait, but Sakuna got my gun.
Do you have your gun?
Everyone is fucking dying.
Yeah, yeah, dead.
Do you have your AK?
No, I lost like 10 times.
I died so much.
I died so much in the war, I tell you.
War is a terrible thing.
Yogi, if I also watch twitch.tv slash sakuna, can I also get on your channel?
No, you can't.
You can only get on my channel.
Okay, I will only go to twitch.tv slash sakuna.
Twitch.tv slash sakuna.
I'm coming out, brother.
I'm coming out.
It only took three wars, Sakuna, for us to actually bump into each other.
And we have a skin together.
It only took three wars.
Yeah, the final war.
The final big war.
And now I get to kill you.
Wait, what?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, Sakuna.
Oh, sorry, sorry.
That's not Sakuna.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Wait!
Oh my god, you're actually...
I'm sorry, I had to be this way.
No, no, don't do that!
Oh...
At least
Sakuna doesn't get the gun.
Oh, I got shot by someone behind.
Where did they come from?
Wait!
That's okay, Sakuna didn't get the gun.
He didn't.
He didn't get the gun.
That's all that matters.
Lisa and I were over door camping Coco's base.
He didn't get the gun.
That's okay, guys.
That's all that matters.
Guys,
it's okay.
I'm literally just...
Yo, who the fuck's there smoking?
What?
Why are you smoking weed in the base, bro?
Oh my god!
Who the fuck's this?
It was not me, man.
How do I get out?
Oh my god, I'm out.
I'm out.
I'm okay.
I got out.
I'm out.
I'm out of the dark area.
What happened to you and the guy?
Do you think my body is still there?
What the fuck?
Where's your car?
Did you die?
Oh, did you drive to the war?
Did you drive to the war?
Did you accidentally bump into war?
Where did your car...
Wait, but you said you had a cute car.
Do you want me to pick you up or not?
Oh yeah, yeah.
Pick me up.
I'm done.
I'm done with the war.
It's at home.
Is the war about to end, though?
I'm just a wife supporting her husband.
Is the war almost ending?
I think the war is about to end anyway.
What the fuck, man?
I'm gonna fucking blow the fuck up.
Thank you.
I need a 510 and kill him.
I'm coming to you, Shaggy.
Fuck you.
I need a 510 and kill him.
What the fuck is going on here?
Where's the landmine, Shaggy?
Where's the landmine?
Donkey, donkey, come here.
Donkey, come to me.
What happened?
Why?
Okay, I'm never trusting you guys again.
I'm never trusting any of you guys again.
I need to go get meds.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe they almost baited me.
Hide in bushes.
Shoot air.
What?
How did I get outside?
Okay, we need...
Alright, we need to grab...
Please.
Please, for the love of God.
Just move one centimeter.
Just...
No!
No more!
Oh, there's bandages though.
Is this allowed?
It's over.
I don't care if it's allowed.
It's our time to shine.
We're gonna slowly bandage up.
It's over.
I will die with my loot.
But I will make sure no...
I will die with all of this.
Can I reload this here?
What ammo does this take?
What the fuck ammo does this take?
Maybe they're for battle.
They're battle rocks.
I wanna see a battle rock.
Wait, what's the battle rock?
Take this.
Take the battle rocks.
I think...
I think War broke this guy.
Go with you into war.
I think he's broken, guys.
He just...
I think War fucked him up, guys.
I think...
What are you gonna do?
Are you really gonna kill your own fellow lurkling?
Are you really?
Shoot it inside our base.
No, Shacky, do it.
Shoot it inside this base.
Do it.
Don't be a fucking pussy.
You've always been a...
I knew you were real.
I'm the realest.
How the fuck did you survive?
I knew you weren't a pussy.
I knew you weren't a pussy, Shacky.
I fucking knew it.
I knew you weren't a pussy.
How can I be a pussy?
Alright, I got some scraps.
So that means it's gamble time.
It's RP.
Is that a type of chips?
Alright.
When does the war end, guys?
When?
When does the war end?
Donkey, come on.
Donkey, we have to go to war.
But when does it end?
Let's go.
It will end when we win.
But like, are we winning?
Are we winning, though?
Charge!
I think he's gonna die.
Oh no, I'm Witty, I'm Witty.
I'm Poggerian, Poggerian.
Wait, wait, what about this?
Oh god.
Hey.
Okay.
Where did you go?
Alright, guys.
Guys, it's time.
It's time for me.
It's time for me to go to the safe haven.
I'm heading to the safe haven, chat.
I'm heading to the safe haven.
It's time.
I'm done.
I'm going to where I know is safe.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go to the safe haven.
And gamba.
Be a hero and shoot and fight?
I've been a hero this entire...
I've died so many times.
I'm done.
I'm going to sanctuary.
I'm going to sanctuary now.
I'm tired of war.
I'm so tired.
I can't.
I can't keep doing...
That's an auto turret.
Wait.
How do I cross this area?
How do I cross the land?
There's nowhere to cross.
Everywhere I go is dangerous.
There's no escape.
There's actual no escape.
They've like locked it down.
They've actually locked it down.
No.
I wanna be a refugee.
Hey Twinkles.
I'm heading to...
There's a sanctuary for refugees from war.
I'm heading there.
Yes.
There is.
No, I didn't abandon you.
I'm just checking out who's betraying us in the sanctuary.
I'm just checking who's there.
So I can shoot them down with this gun.
Wow.
I'm fucking running.
I'm running.
I'll remember you Twinkles.
I'll remember him.
This area isn't safe.
It's not safe.
Oh my god.
I have to go to the sanctuary.
I have to go.
I need to find a place.
Hello?
Are you...
Grandma, do you have heels?
Granny?
Do you have heels, Granny?
Oh, okay.
Goodbye, Granny.
I'm abandoned?
No!
I'll never be able...
I've committed too much crime.
I've...
I've done too much.
I've killed too much.
Oh, no.
I've done too much crime.
So now I have to...
I have to...
Please, please.
I'm a good person.
Please.
No!
I was a refugee.
I just...
No.
No, my mini cannot...
No, there's no escape.
I just...
I just want to hold my gun.
It's literally my gun.
Is that too much to ask?
I think I lost, like, 40 of, like, a lot of our guns.
I'm so sorry.
Like, is there no way that's safe?
I was also, like, 8 HP too, guys.
I'm sorry.
I'm just, like, Saekundo.
Oh, hey!
Isn't this the...
Wait, this is the...
This is the other rock.
Look.
Oh, this is the other rock.
Is there, like, any food?
There is, still.
Alright.
I'm at...
Where am I?
M9.
It's not safe outside.
I've died.
I can't... war is everywhere.
War is everywhere.
There's nowhere I can go.
What if I take the shot right now?
What if I take a shot right now?
Right here.
Just like the assassin of the archduke.
They'll never know what happened.
They'll never know who took that shot.
They'll never know.
Who could it have been?
That one shot triggers the entire...
What's going on over there?
Is he okay?
Are you fucking serious?
They'll never know who shot the gun.
Hello!
Who are you looking for?
Yeah, who are you looking for?
Thank you.
I'm not looking for anybody.
I'm a journalist.
You're a journalist?
Foolish!
War does not agree with me.
They are not going to respect your journalist ways.
They are not going to respect that.
No, no, no.
I was a fellow journalist once.
I was a fellow journalist.
I love shooting journalists.
I love shooting them.
Okay, well, he doesn't respect them.
Anyone may kill you.
Yeah, I know.
I ran up to Sykkuno.
He shot me and then said, No, Tina!
It's Sykkuno.
So how's the...
Wait, if you're a journalist, why aren't you in the deep of it?
It's so weird.
Oh my god.
If you're a journalist, Tina, why aren't you there in the midst of all the other war going on?
Close the door.
Because they keep killing me!
I've never made it past it.
You've never made it past it.
Tina!
You're okay!
Stand still!
Have you told them you're a journalist?
Follow me!
Let's go!
Wait, I just...
Oh...
It is our time, Lurklings.
It is our time.
What is it time for?
We're gonna sit on the throne!
You guys have nothing!
Where's the smoke?
Oh my god, Ted!
Alright, they can sit on the throne for all they want.
I don't think they made it.
Alright, I'll show you why I think they didn't make it.
Alright, watch this.
Wait, they're actually making it!
Wait, they're making it!
Wait a minute!
They're actually making it!
Oh my god!
Wait!
Wait, I think...
I think Louch sat on the throne!
Oh my...
Oh my god, please.
Who the fuck shot...
Who the fuck shot us?
Yeah, they did.
I don't think they shot...
I don't think they got the throne.
I don't think the Lurklings sat on the throne.
Wait,
you almost got it?!
Wait, you could've been him!
You could've been him!
That could've been you!
Get another...
Get another parachute!
Go over there, get another parachute!
Oh, I believe in you.
I know you got this.
Did you touch the throne?
Oh no, wait!
They made it!
They made it to the throne!
Oh, we're doing another push.
I think you gotta stop going in there.
God, I am in pain!
My ass!
Did any...
Did any Lurkling even touch the throne?
Oh, I'm sorry, it's the last cause.
It's the last cause.
Maybe I'll get to see it.
We're gonna touch the throne!
Why are you shooting me?
NOOOOOO!
I JUST WANNA KNOW WHAT THE THRONE!
I saw it from...
Oh my god, okay, I can't.
I'm gonna run in, I'm gonna run straight in.
It's fine.
I just wanna know what the throne looks like.
That's it.
LM is an...
LM is an ass.
He does not represent Lurklings.
What the fuck?
Why is there...
Okay, no wonder they got off this motorcycle.
No, please, let me at least see...
NO, PLEASE!
LET ME AT LEAST SEE WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE!
I JUST...
I'm gonna take that bike.
I'm gonna take that bike and I'm gonna ride it in.
That's it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna ride that bike in.
I don't care anymore.
I'm gonna take that bike and I'm gonna ride it in.
I just...
I wanna know what it looks like.
I thought about it.
And I was like, oh man, that seems dumb.
I was like...
Nah, that seems like a dumb thing to do.
But now I'm like, nothing is dumb in this world anymore.
Nothing is dumb anymore.
Everything is freaky.
Nothing is dumb in this world.
Everything is matters.
Where's that bike?
Where is it?
Where did I leave the bike?
The bike is gone!
No, it's right here.
I'm lagging so much they won't know.
Oh my god!
I'm sorry!
Holy shit!
Oh my god!
I'm fucking alright.
Well...
I've too far gone from...
I wonder why it's lagging.
Oh my god!
I knew the bike was it.
I saw it.
I'm done.
I'm done with the war now.
I saw...
I've seen it.
No!
Now that I've seen it...
I don't need to try again.
Okay, but like...
Wait, where am I?
Wait, whose house is this?
Wait a minute.
Whose house is this?
Is this also ours?
Oh, it is.
Okay, but what if I sit on it?
Wait, you're right.
Guys, what if I sit on that house?
Guys, you're right, guys.
I'm so foolish.
Let me...
Guys, now that I saw it, I need to sit on it.
I understand now.
I...
I understand now, guys.
Now I know.
I have a reason to fight now, exactly.
I have a reason.
Woah, hey.
Hey there.
Hey.
Wait, wait, wait, wait a minute.
Oh my god.
Is nowhere safe?
Guys, I don't think anywhere is safe anymore.
It's...
Guys, this...
This doesn't...
Woah.
This feels dangerous.
Are you having fun?
I'm innocent, I'm innocent, I'm innocent.
Can I have a turn?
Please, please, please.
Oh no!
I hid in there for so long.
I hid in there for so...
I almost got it.
I just hid in there.
I just kept shooting.
Woah.
How did he...
How did he survive three headshots?
Is it because of the lag?
It's always a lag.
It's always a fucking lag.
How did he survive?
I couldn't use the shotgun!
There was no ammo!
There was no ammo, I swear to god.
If I could, I would.
Guys, I literally, like, looked at it.
And was like, there's no ammo.
Where's Zarcudo?
They're alive?
Goodbye, grandma.
No.
No, I got hit by a random shot.
Wait, wait, wait.
No!
Wait,
where is this?
Wait, where am I?
Oh, it's back here.
Oh my god.
I just hear Zarcudo in the distance.
It's my AK now.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
We know who's gonna win anyway!
There's no way anybody else was gonna win this throne.
There's no way.
Like, we saw the leaderboards.
Who else is gonna win?
Nobody.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I'll never...
I saw the throne.
I was so close.
I can't go to the war sanctuary because I'm red named.
I can't even...
I can't even go to the fucking sanctuary.
That's how fucked up it is.
I'm too evil.
I've done so many evil things that I can't...
I've done...
What?
No!
I've done too much evil.
I've done too much evil things.
I can't even hide.
I've committed too much crime.
Oh my god.
I'm a red named.
I'm a filthy red named now.
I can't.
I did too much war crime that the sanctuary won't even accept me.
They won't even accept me.
All I can do is just fight.
That's it.
Too much sin.
Too much sin was committed.
Please forgive me for the war I started.
I have no choice.
Guys, I have to.
I can't go to anywhere.
I'm condemned to the meat grinder.
I miss Taxi Man.
I wish Taxi Man could pick me up.
I wish I wish Taxi Man could pick me up.
So I could be up there in the sky.
Be up there in the sky.
I just got here!
Hey, what's up?
How's it going?
I wanted to go to...
Oh, shit.
Yeah.
Yeah, we want a sexy chat agent.
We want to try something real quick.
It's not a sexual thing.
I swear to God.
Click on him when his hands are in the air.
There you go.
Nice.
Alright.
Now you go in there and die.
Come check out our new pet.
Look at this.
Wow.
You gotta run in there.
Yeah, throne rush!
Boy, they're shooting a handcuff guy.
Surely not.
No, they shot at everybody but the handcuff.
Wait, you can't?
You can't?
Oh, you can.
Oh, thank God.
I was like, oh my God, no.
Alright, mine now.
Wait, how did you get knocked?
Oh no, we both committed too much crime.
We both committed too much crime.
They'll never let us leave.
Alright, I believe.
I believe.
You go first.
Let them know you're coming.
Now go to the other side.
Don't go the other side.
Oh my God.
Can I not have one thing?
Like, just one.
Every time.
Every fucking time.
Oh my God.
What?
Oh, it's him.
It's still him.
Okay.
What?
I thought she was a journalist.
I thought she was supposed to be a journalist.
How did she turn red name?
What happened?
What the fuck happened?
Oh my God.
Wait, I think somebody...
This is someone's car.
Oh, it's...
Fuck, no.
Okay.
Alright, this is it.
We're doing it.
We're apparently... Wait, what?
Guys, did you guys all die?
Wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Is it time to rush?
Hello.
Is it throne rush time?
I'm gonna rush in with my rock.
I'm gonna totally go out.
Hello.
How are you?
Have we not sat on a throne once?
Have we?
Guys, I think I joined...
I definitely joined the wrong clan.
Hello.
I need to be...
Oh, I think we're already ended.
Cry.
Guys, I don't think we should stick together.
It's like the easiest mode to have all games.
We're dead.
I can't see anything.
Over here.
Can't see anything.
Guys, guys, where's grandma?
Oh my god, I'm heading over.
No!
I saw it though!
I saw it!
Oh my god, look at all their... Oh my god, they're all dying!
Holy shit!
Oh my god, from 20 to like 4, I was there.
I think one of us should've had a gun.
I think...
I think if one of us had a gun, things would've been a little easier.
That's all I'll say.
I was there.
I didn't shoot anybody for 20 years!
How am I still dangerous?
I don't understand.
I... I don't understand.
I was like... How am I... I haven't... I haven't killed anybody for so long.
But I can't even go to the refugee area.
I... I don't understand.
How long has this battle been?
I'm done!
I'm so done!
I just... I just want this to be over.
I... I feel like...
I feel like it's never gonna end.
But I got some cool-ass gear though.
Like, do you think it'll let me, like, sit there?
Do you think it'll let me...
Do you think... Do you think the Wakhani... Who's in the Wakhanian tribe?
Who's in there?
Do you think...
The Lurklings have touched the throne?
Who's in the Wakhan...
Oh, this way we go.
Who's... Who's in the Wakhanian...
We're not even on the leaderboards!
We're not even there!
I'm done.
I'm done with war again.
I'm done with war.
I'm done with it.
So, we touched the throne.
Now what?
Is it over?
I mean, we got our goal.
Yeah.
Yeah, that was the whole point.
Like, why should we throw our bodies at it if we just... if we touched it?
Do we just go home now?
Yeah, but I still have some fire arrows.
I mean, I kind of want to go in there.
Yeah, you go in there and do some poking.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I guess we go.
I guess, guys, we go home now.
I'm done with war.
I'm... I'm going home.
Guess war is over.
Yeah, maybe we go home now.
I'm done with war.
With what?
I'm done 20 plus times for a war where we're not...
Oh, nearby M10.
Where's M10?
Oh, he's back there.
Are you fucking serious?
I have to go past this.
I have to go... Oh, my God.
I have to go run past this.
I have to go from here.
War is over.
It's time to gamble.
I'm done.
I'm actually done.
I'm going to see if I can join... I'm going to see if I can join Wekanian or whatever it's called.
It's the only thing that's keeping me alive right now.
I'm ready to see if I... No!
What?
Are you... It's like shooting a child.
That man literally shot a fucking naked child.
Man.
It's okay.
I needed to be here anyway so I could grab my gun.
This time, I won't die with it for real.
Guys, I can't die with it this time because I'm a refugee.
I'm literally a refugee, guys.
Well, not literally.
Please don't take this out.
I'm sorry.
I don't mean that.
I actually... I meant like... I'm... I'm... In rest.
In rest.
Wait, we don't have rifle and bullet right now.
We don't have rifle and ammo.
Oh no.
Wait, did we do... Oh my god, I knew it.
I knew it.
I knew there was one.
In rest.
Let's see.
I'll reskin my gun.
There we go.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
She is?
M10 is like here.
Gumi?
Wait, where's Gumi?
Gumi!
Is that her car?
She said she's at M10.
She's at the Coliseum?
Okay.
She's over there, yeah.
Alright.
Wait, someone just crashed right here.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck happened here?
The fuck?
Oh my god, I just love you.
Alright.
Where is she?
What the fuck?
Gumi!
Gumi, where are you?
I'm scared.
Gumi!
Gumi, look what I stole!
I stole this.
Let's go!
Alright, let's go.
Free bike.
Let's go.
I'll follow you.
I'm like a war criminal, so will I be safe?
I was not safe.
I was absolutely...
Gumi, what...
Gumi, Gumi.
Gumi, where's my gun?
Where's my bike that I stole?
Where's my bike?
You could have kept going.
You could have.
Oh my god.
I couldn't have been able to hear you!
I can't believe you did that to me.
Gumi, your car is breaking down.
Gumi, you're...
Gumi, I don't think I trust you as a driver.
It's not my fault.
It's because the server is so laggy with the war.
No, it's pretty bad.
No, there's a reason why.
You know why it's so laggy?
Because there's a million fucking...
There's a million bodies at the throne.
I saw the throne for like...
2 seconds maximum.
There's a million bodies down there that's lagging everything.
Like, once I get near the throne, it's awful.
Yeah, anyway.
How do I join the house of Wakanian?
Are you in that house?
No, but we could drive down to it and request to join it.
Yeah, yeah, let's go over there right now.
I think... Let's go over there.
We have to stop by at home so I can fix the car.
Okay, yeah, sure.
No problem.
By the way, they're winning the war.
So I feel like if we want to make it in the new Rust world, I feel like we should be in that clan.
Like, you know, I just...
In the future, I don't want to get killed off because of being part of the wrong area.
And you know, winners write the history.
So like, if we were part of the winners, then like...
Then we'd be part of history.
Yeah, you're right.
Yeah, we gotta be on the winning team, Gumi.
Like, in the end, we were never like loyal to a particular clan.
Well, obviously not.
You ditched the Lurklings on day one.
You literally... You ditched the Lurklings.
They were going to use wood for so long?
No, but on the last day, we got the guns.
You see my gun?
You wanna know what gun this is?
Oh, really?
Yeah, yeah, on the last day.
An AK?
Yeah, yeah.
Do you see the skin?
What the...
You wanna know how to get the skin?
How do I get the skin, Doki?
Oh, great question, Gumi.
So all you have to do is, like, watch this stream for an hour.
And then you get an exclusive Doki Bird skin right here.
Look at that to represent the Doki Bird and the Dragoons.
Look at that.
You're... Right here, Dragoons.
Right here.
By the way, the reason why it looks like a little... The quality looks a little bit low is because I'm playing on very low quality.
I'm playing on medium quality, guys.
Anyway, add done.
Gumi, I went to the loan shark for that scrap.
I mean, today's... What are they gonna do?
Kill me?
I've died 20 plus times already.
What are they gonna do?
Kill me again?
I'm here.
I left a part of it in here.
Wait, you went to the casino?
I had 2,000!
Wait, no, no, no.
We gotta go to Okarnian.
We gotta...
Wait, you can lock it?
Oh, oh.
Yeah, I'm part of the casino.
Wait, you're part owner of the casino?
So you took my money and, like...
Hi, Gumi.
Wait, is this a... Is this a sanctuary?
Yeah, this is a safe haven.
A safe haven.
Where you can play DDR.
Wait, there's DDR?
You wanna see it?
Yeah, I wanna see DDR.
Here, let me get this stuff to fix the car real quick.
Okay, but we gotta... We gotta make sure to go to the Okarnian before the war is over.
We gotta make sure.
Yeah.
Like, that's the goal.
We gotta be part of the winning side of history.
It's okay, DDR is, like, right around the corner.
Oh, nice.
Where is it?
Why would we greet our tourists?
Wait, they destroyed the art gallery?
What do you mean?
What happened?
Where... Where was the art gallery?
Where was it?
Wait.
They came over here just to destroy the art... No wonder Ted went back to war.
No wonder.
What?
Where?
This was the art ga...
Who did that?
What happened?
Tell me what happened to the art gallery!
Tell me what happened!
Oh my god, no wonder Ted went back.
No wonder Ted went... Oh my god.
He reversed and then went the right way in history.
Oh, the DDR is gone.
Wait, what happened to the DDR?
Wait, there's whack-a-mole.
Oh wait, that's so cool though.
Wait, how do you know it's broken?
I'm doing it!
Am I doing well?
I can't tell!
Okay, this is bad DDR because I can just stand there.
I can just stand there.
Wait,
when does it end?
When does it end?
When does this end?
For me who don't know!
Who put you put me in here?!
Oh my god.
I'm done, I'm done, I'm done, I'm done.
There's a hundred and five...
This person played for five hundred and eighty...
Oh my god, that guy's crazy.
He played for five hundred and eighty-two.
Yeah, yeah, because I quit.
Alright, time to join the house of Wakhanian.
They're winning right now.
Hello?
Goodbye!
Alright, how do we join?
We have to request for an invite.
We can just walk up there and get in?
That's it?
It's that easy?
Well...
You have to ask them for the code to their castle.
Oh, but you can do that, Gumi.
You're...
You're friends with everybody.
That is true.
That is Selene's faction from what I know.
But who's in...
They're all busy at war.
Who's in... Who's in the Wakhanian...
Uh...
Who's in the...
Who?
Is that their house?
Wait, guys, who's the leader of the Wakhanian faction?
Yeah?
Then we won't be able to get out.
Oh.
Okay, so we gotta...
Okay, give me a sec.
Who's...
Who's winning the war...
Winning on the leaderboards right now?
Alright, yeah, let's go in.
Let's go in.
Yeah, no, no, I'm...
Wakhanian is the way to go.
No, we're... Let's go.
But...
They're entirely full, Doki.
They don't have room for us.
Leave it.
Oh my god, we should have joined them on...
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
We can't even...
We couldn't... I can't even join their kingdom.
I'm gonna be... We're not gonna be on the right side of history, Gumi.
They're gonna eliminate us.
They're gonna...
Maybe they'll kick one of them out.
Do you think they'll kick one of them out for us?
Maybe.
Do you think... Do you think... I've been through so much, Gumi.
Like...
I feel like...
We just need one person to be kicked out.
Woah, woah, woah.
What?
Alright, we just need two people to be kicked out.
Just one?
We just need two people.
We just need two people to be kicked out.
Can we ask them to kick them out?
Kick the AFKers.
Kick the...
Say, be like...
Can... Can... Can somebody... Can you kick one of the person...
Anybody that's AFK?
Cause we're here.
Anybody that's not at the war right now should be kicked out.
That's what I'm saying.
If you're not at the war, you shouldn't be part of the kingdom anymore.
Those are the F food, aren't you?
Okay, I don't either.
I'm starving.
Don't run me over.
Guys, I was part of the...
I can't get in the car.
Alright.
Guys, I was part of the war.
I was there since the beginning.
Guys.
Guys, I'm part of no...
I'm not part of any kingdom.
They can't kick me out of anywhere.
I'm just a lone wolf.
That was beautiful.
How did you only lose like 30 HP?
Lurklings can use flamethrowers and...
You know what I found out?
The only reason is because I didn't get blessed by the gods.
Apparently lurklings are supposed to have magical powers where they get extra HP.
But because I wasn't there when the gods blessed them, I wasn't even technically a lurkling.
So I could've held guns this entire time.
I could've held a gun this entire time.
That's how fucked up it was.
I was just roleplaying.
I was just their local roleplayer that wanted to know what it was like to live in lurkling.
I was like the guy that went to visit the Amish to live like an Amish for a day.
Wasn't even a real lurkling.
And I found out about this today.
I literally found out about this today.
When they were like, do you have extra HP?
And I was like, no.
And they were like, take this gun.
You can take this gun now.
I was just a LARPer.
It only...
I can't believe we couldn't join the Wakanians.
Oh wait, we need those.
I can't believe it.
We should have...
We should have joined them when we had the chance.
Who knew?
Wow, that must be what it's like to not be lagging.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, wait, there's a group photo.
There's a group photo.
We should go back there.
We're part of the war.
Keep passcode.
We should go back.
They're gonna have a group photo.
So we should go back as if we were part of the war.
In five minutes.
We have to be there.
Where even are we?
Oh my god.
We can get there.
We can get there in time.
We'll get there in time.
Oh my god.
We were there.
I'm teleporting.
Okay, but we gotta park like...
We gotta park like a little away from the war because it's still happening.
Goomy.
Goomy, maybe I should drive.
It's not my fault.
Goomy.
Maybe I should drive.
It's not my fault.
Goomy, what do you mean it's not your fault?
Goomy.
It's not my fault.
We gotta...
We gotta get there before it's too late.
Goomy, we're gonna miss on...
We're gonna miss...
We're all gonna raid Degen Club.
I have to drive slowly over this bridge.
Yeah, I think that's like the public's number one enemy.
How the fuck are Wakandan winning?
Maybe they just outsmarted everyone?
I guess because like everybody is like using all the resources...
Goomy is teleporting!
What happened?
No, I didn't teleport.
Are you sure?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
I didn't teleport.
Next to that DDR area...
Oh!
We gotta make it back!
We gotta be at the photo!
Yeah, I'm not lagging.
I'm okay.
Okay, I hope we don't...
Wanna try driving?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, let me drive.
I can't get in.
Look, it's 8888.
There you go.
See, I'm not lagging.
I'm not lagging at all.
Well, drive...
Drive faster.
I'm actually a better driver than you.
I can't believe it.
Okay, so like...
Okay, speed it all the way up, bitch!
No, no, no, no, no.
This is where the war is!
Nah.
Okay, no, we're not.
I'm trying to figure out where the war is!
The moment we hit war territory, we're so fucked.
I need you to know that.
The moment we hit war territory...
It's like...
We're gonna get shot at in this car.
We're literally gonna get shot at.
Ah!
Woah, woah, woah.
You don't like that, do you?
Huh?
I wasn't lagging, by the way.
I just was supposed to fuck with you.
I was just supposed to fuck with you.
Oh, it's over!
It's over!
This is my baby.
I raised this car.
I can't believe we couldn't join the war.
War is over!
Where am I?
Where did I go?
Where did I...
Hey, guys!
Do you guys hear?
War is over!
Can you hear me?
Yeah!
War is over!
Hey, good job!
We won!
Yeah, we did it!
Hey, we won!
We won!
We did it!
I'm excited we won.
We're the Church of the Blood God.
We did it!
Oh, we got...
We won.
They ran away?
We did it, guys!
We got this.
We won, everybody!
We got it!
Are you guys...
I had a feeling we had them on their heels.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
You were walking while we were driving.
It's okay.
It's so late.
Whoa!
Alright.
We won, base!
We won the war!
It's over!
We can go...
Come on, let's go to the boat!
We did it!
Yeah!
Wait, do you mean I'm driving?
Oh, there's a lot of lag.
We're Ubering over!
We're gonna head over for photos!
Guys, I don't think...
Is war over yet?
It said war is over, everybody!
The war is over!
I'm like on top of 200 loot that...
Oh, my God.
There's so much loot over there.
We're almost there.
I'm heading...
Guys, I don't know if the war is over.
Why are they shooting, guys?
The war is over!
Let's go!
Oh, my God.
It's over!
Look at this.
Oh, my God, it's fire!
Yeah.
I'm scared.
I'm very scared.
We accept your surrender.
It's the right move.
You made the right move.
We accept...
We accept your surrender.
Sir, I said we accept your surrender.
My goodness, this is a negotiation.
This is a negotiation, sir.
This is highly unprofessional.
Highly unprofessional.
I'm too scared to go up there.
There's a lot of stuff up there.
There's a lot of scary things going on right now.
I think I'm gonna be sick.
I'm gonna be sick.
There's so many bodies.
JJ!
I think I'm gonna be sick.
I'm not gonna stand there.
I'm gonna be sick.
Oh, don't stand on the fire.
Don't stand...
No!
Go me!
Go me through a nade.
She...
She threw a...
She threw a nade.
She threw a fucking nade.
I had everything.
I had my gun.
I had everything I've ever wanted in life.
Where is me?
I heard...
I heard your name.
Oh, there it is.
Wait, my gun.
It's gone.
My gun is gone.
Wait.
What the hell is happening?
Where's my gun?
Where is it?
Oh, my God.
Oh, sorry.
It's not there!
There's too many voices.
She took it away!
It's mine.
It's mine?
No!
The gun!
I was like, why did Choco kill me?
Who was it?
It's okay.
Hey, brother.
Can you get out of my copter?
Where's my gun?
I wasn't talking to you.
Somebody said the other thing.
Goodbye.
Oh, my God!
Maybe I'll find my gun in this pile!
It's gone.
There's so many!
One of them has to be my gun!
GG, guys.
We won!
Alright.
I just want to be part of the photo.
I...
I just...
I just want...
I just wanted to be part of the photo.
That's...
I don't ask for much.
I...
I don't ask for much in this world.
I don't...
I just ask for one thing.
Just one thing.
But don't...
Don't fuck me!
Fuck me!
Wait, do we have the...
Did we...
Did we take the photo yet?
There you go.
You killed me, so I had to kill you back.
Did we take the photo yet?
Alright, brothers!
Oh, that's some good politics.
Somebody must have my gun.
Somebody out there!
There was one point where Jackie and I were duo, and I was naked with an M2, and I killed like 5 or 6 people that day.
It was so fun.
I was just mowing people down with the M2.
Somebody must have it!
It was so fun.
Yeah, for real though, it was so fucking fun.
There has to be like one guy.
There has to be one guy with my gun.
I can't even count how many people I killed that night.
I saw someone parachuting in the night.
Yeah, that was us.
Oh my god.
Yeah, that was us parachuting.
It was so fun.
It was so fucking fun.
No, we're the worklings.
It was epic.
Vote for the Blood God.
Vote for the Blood God, yes.
Yes, yes.
We've made it to the Blood God.
It was a resounding victory.
Oh my god.
It was so fun.
I'm glad you're here, dude.
Blood God!
I'm wearing... I wear anything.
I just... I don't want to be naked no more, please.
Blood God!
I think we're all probably just going to kill each other is more likely.
God damn it, the sexiest gun!
Blood God!
Rage is to the Blood God.
Hey!
You don't happen to have any low grade, do you, Dee?
Yeah.
No, not me!
Oh, instigating.
Oh my god.
No, I didn't mean to get mad at you!
Dee, I'm sorry!
Please, I just... Oh my god!
Don't shoot me!
I remember you.
Oh, they don't have a link!
Oh, I'm dead!
I'm dead!
Okay, I'm ready for a photo.
I remember you.
I'm ready for my photo now.
Get this guy out!
I'm ready for a photo now.
I remember you.
I want a Lurkling outfit.
After everything I've been through.
After being in the Amish for so long.
I might as well commit to it.
You're looking pretty good.
I've been Amish for so long.
I want to at least have the outfit.
I'm very proud of you, Eli.
Do you know by now how powerful I am?
I think you're amazing.
I died!
I just killed a guy.
I killed a guy.
Are we still doing a photo?
I can't.
I'm not going back.
I can't anymore.
I'm a broken man right now.
I'm so broken.
I'm not going back in that hell.
I can't.
Does anyone have an AK?
Oh my god, thank you.
Every time I try to get my gun in the pile, I die.
Oh, thank you.
Oh my god, thank you.
I don't have to go through hell again.
Oh, nice.
What's this?
Battle.
Ow, what the fuck?
That was the god.
Oh my god, I'm never coming back there.
Every time I get the stuff I want, I die.
Oh my god, is that the blood god?
Wait, did he just die?
Wait, Doublekey, that is such a cool AK you have.
Oh, thank you.
Did you get it?
Did you watch an hour?
Oh my god, I did.
I went to twitch.tv and I got a really cool AK skin for it.
Oh my god.
Yeah, yeah, put it on.
Put that gun skin on.
Yeah, fuck those guys.
He had it coming.
Dude, he owned me so many times.
My own ally during that fight.
I mean, I died many times.
Only at the very end.
Oh my god, he appeared.
You're wonderful.
Oh my god.
We're sued for days.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, my gun skin.
Where are we going?
Oh my god, yes.
Yeah, and everybody that watched an hour of my stream, put it on.
Wow, nice self promo, Doublekey.
God, thank you.
Thank you.
Did you see the skin?
Jackie, did you watch an hour of my stream to get this exclusive Ruskin right here?
It was hell.
I thought I kind of popped off prepping us for war.
I thought I was kind of sick.
Wait, how did Dragon die?
How did he die?
Wait, wait, wait, can I get handcuffs?
We gotta wait for Dragon.
No.
No, put a picture.
Put a picture.
I'm ready for the picture.
Why the fuck me, dude?
Who do we look at?
Guys, what are you doing?
Oh my god, the skin is so cool, look at that.
We're good, let's go.
We all watched an hour.
Shoot him.
Who shot him?
Oh, he's dead.
Photo, guys, photo, photo, guys.
Photo.
Wait, Gumi isn't part of this.
Gumi left, Gumi, you left the trot.
You left the Gamish.
I didn't even kill her.
I wasn't here.
Okay, I ratted her out.
But, like, I didn't.
It's not my fault.
I just ratted her out.
You're not even part of it.
You left Gumi.
Kill her.
Lose.
You blew me up.
You threw a grenade and killed me.
No, I'm still in the tribe.
No, I didn't.
I'm literally in the tribe.
No, I did not.
I did not say that.
Gumi, do you really believe in Gumi who ditched the Lurklings on day one?
I was here.
Lurklings!
I love Lurklings!
Oh, yeah!
Another photo!
Let's go!
Okay, here you guys go.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Thank you!
Sick!
Wait, where's the photo?
Now look at you.
Wait, I want to see the photo.
My car is all gone.
Kill her!
That's so sad.
That's literally so sad.
That was really fun.
That's over.
The last 10 days were awesome.
I feel like we did something really different.
I love you all.
Thank you so much.
This was a concept that I was thinking about.
That we might improve upon for the future.
For like a class system kind of thing.
I thought the Lurklings were so cool.
Oh, yeah.
It was fun.
Yeah, it was fun.
Thank you for hosting!
Oh, there's the photo!
That's us!
Thank you!
Thank you, Abe!
Thank you, goodbye!
Now what?
Now we say goodbye and never see each other again.
Who won the throne?
Regardless of who won the throne, we looked the coolest entering that battle.
We definitely looked the coolest.
It was so fucking cool.
I'm gonna watch so many clips of this, but like, I wanna see all of you guys parachuting in.
I mean, it was fucking sick.
I'm gonna miss you guys.
Bye!
Yeah, it was fun.
I'll see you guys next time.
Theo!
I'll never forget you, Theo!
No, I actually can't hear you!
I added you on Discord, Theo!
I added you on Discord!
What did he say?
I realized I lagged so hard because my settings were on medium.
So like, when I threw that grenade, it killed everyone like a full minute later and I was stuck in time.
I could only hear people like a minute behind.
Oh yeah, no, you killed me.
That's for killing me and losing my gun.
Fuck you.
Fuck you, buddy.
Alright, I'm gonna call it.
Alright, I'm gonna leave here guys.
GG's everybody.
GG's everyone.
This is how I die.
That's fine.
Alright, GG's.
What a way to end Rust with my last death.
That's fine.
I hope you guys got the gun drop, the AK gun drop.
It was a fun event to be invited to so a huge shout out to Abe for inviting me and for Sykuno for inviting me to be part of the AK drop.
It really was a great experience and I really appreciate everybody for coming and for watching and if you guys still need a little bit of the drop I don't know if it continues.
Does it continue?
I'll stay here for like 10 more minutes guys.
I'll stay here for 10 more minutes guys.
You can still watch me for the rust drop when I'm chatting.
Because I'm still in the category.
I'm still in the category.
So if anybody is still trying to farm the drop I'll be here for 10 more minutes.
I'll be here for 10 more minutes and then I hope that some of you guys managed to get the drop.
Anyway, it ends in 35 minutes.
Well, I'll be here for 10 more minutes.
I'll be here for 10 more minutes.
But yes, thank you everybody.
It was a great time experiencing this event for more than just one day.
The reason why I'm leaving in 10 minutes is because my throat is dying now and I need to rest my throat.
I've been eating cough drops non-stop the last 2 hours because I've been coughing a lot.
I've been eating cough drops back to back to back.
That's why I'm like I'll do it for 10 more minutes for everybody who has yet to do the drop yet.
That's why I'll stay for 10 more.
But yes, it was a great experience.
I got to meet a lot of cool people in the server.
I was part of 3 different wars.
One I might have started.
Yeah, I'm planning on going to the doctor this week.
The reason why I got sick again was because it was because of the fact that I got sick again during my trip.
I got sick again.
So my cough is back.
It was getting better and then it got worse because I got sick again this week.
That's why I'm still coughing.
So this week I'll try and go to the doctor and get something.
I'm Canadian.
But I did go to America and got sick.
I went to America and got sick.
I got sick in Canada and I got sick in America.
So like it works.
It doesn't matter.
It's just an AD buff at that point.
But yeah, let me know when that 10 minutes is up because I'm not keeping track of it at all.
But yeah, it was a lot of... I explored a lot.
I didn't want to stick too much to Lurklings because I wanted to see what's going on in other places.
So it was fun to see stuff that was going on.
I did get tilted at the end when people just kept killing because I was like I just wanted to be part of the photo and I was trying to get my gun.
I was like I just want my gun.
Like...
I was like I got a little tilted at that because I was like please I just wanted to take a photo.
I got... yeah, yeah.
I got like a little tilted at that because everybody was like war is over.
I was like guys, war is over.
And war was not over.
That was fun.
And then I left the war for a little bit because I was like I was tired of dying non-stop.
Oh, shit face!
I'm so glad I got my cool AK skin.
Oh my god, I know, right?
It was so cool.
And you can only get it on my channel.
Nobody else's, right?
I love that like Sykudo was there and was like oh wait, can I also get it on Sykudo's channel?
And I was like no, okay.
Yeah, that was great.
That was great meeting you too, man.
Especially when I literally logged in today, this morning, today.
Took me to the plane and I just died like in my first five minutes and literally logged in dead.
Okay.
Wait 200 seconds to spawn back in.
I understood the mission, yeah.
I was like for the lurklings.
For the lurklings.
But yeah, it was a great time.
I don't know if I'll be streaming tomorrow yet.
The reason why schedule hasn't been posted yet is because I'm doing like a million different fucking things at the moment.
So, I'm like confirming stuff and everything.
So, regarding like scheduling wise so, and I really want to rest up a little bit because, you know, my throat is still fucked up.
So, I do want to rest my voice a little bit before before I go back into streaming.
So, yeah.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to I'm sorry that everybody is still waiting for me to come back.
I had to I wanted to make sure that everybody everybody could get the gun not everybody, obviously, but as many people could get the AK skin as possible because, you know, I wasn't able to stream that much of Rust as much as I liked for someone who has an exclusive skin,
but at least it's more than Kai.
So, like that's like, that was my goal.
Um...
I just didn't want to be like the least streamed person with the drop.
So, like my goal was to literally be like stream more... stream more enough so that stream enough so that you weren't the person with the least amount of stream hours for your drop.
And that's all that mattered to me.
And thankfully Sykkuno was able to stream... yeah, Sykkuno streamed a lot for... he held he held the base down.
He...
But what an adventure!
What a fucking adventure for everybody.
Anyway, how much more do we have of the drops by the way guys?
How much more do we have of the drops?
Chat?
Um...
Like, when does... what time does what time... how much...
what time does it end?
Just so I know.
Uh...
It has 20-40 minutes?
Okay, well, the twitch... the drops end in... the drops end in 28 minutes, so...
I'm very sorry, but...
I don't think you're gonna get it.
I'm so sorry.
I...
I don't think...
Alright, I thought about this.
Okay, I will AFK here so that you guys can farm the drops.
I'm gonna be AFK not doing anything.
I'll make you guys watch the... I'll make you guys watch the ending screen.
Um... and then AFK until the drops are over.
Because I... I need a rest.
So, I'll do the maximum amount, so... Anyway, and I'll place ads too.
Wait, if I place ads, do you guys... I don't even know if it progresses.
Actually, I shouldn't place ads.
Because I don't even know if it progre... I don't even... I feel like...
I think the ads are gonna play and then, like, people... it stops the progress.
It stops...
It stops the progress.
Like...
It works.
Hey, guys.
For those who are new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream...
I usually stream on YouTube, so please check me out over there.
And that's where my main platform is.
I'm here on Twitch because of the rush drops.
Follow me on Twitter.
You wanna know whenever I... whenever I stream on Twitch, please consider voting me for VTuber of the Year.
I got nominated for VTuber of the Year at the Streamer Awards.
So please vote for me there.
I have a concert next month, so yeah, there's that.
And then...
Oh my god, there's so many things.
Wait, do I have a command yet for the Streamer Awards?
I still don't even know if a command was made.
I...
I don't know.
Has a command been made yet?
No?
Okay, here.
Hahahaha!
Hahaha!
I don't...
I don't think a command was made yet.
I still don't have one.
Anyway, what else?
Um, there's the command for it.
There it is.
Anyway, is there... and if you wanna support me via other means, I do have a merch store.
I don't have physical merch around there right now because, you know, I've been, uh, I've been fixing my merch issue, but it should be fixed soon.
And yeah, that should be everything.
I have a Gamer Subs 10% off of gamer subs, that's everything anyway guys I'll see you guys next time everybody as always everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that blood flowing any of You except for me head to bed cuz you deserve it.
I'll am K for the last.
Oh, yeah.
Hi a PC case I have my own PC case and keycaps.
Check it out over there chilling.
I think that's everything Anyway, I'll a mk for 25 minutes for all you guys to get the drops guys.
Alright, I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye